so here's my point when you look at
civics data civic semi if you're not if
you're not familiar there are polling
organization that have a massive map a
time spread going back like five years
of all these different issues you can
see that independent voters people who
are unaffiliated right now
overwhelmingly agree with the right when
it comes to issues of the economy when
it comes to issues of job presidential
performance when it comes to black lives
but you know why that is right why is
that because there are no independent
voters in america anymore it's only
about seven percent
i think the last one is a four percent
like so so lots of people on the right
call themselves independent but like if
you talk about like voting behavior like
people who actually shift like vote
democrats sometimes and vote republican
sometimes that that percentage in
america
negligible it's always been negligible
yes that's true and independent voters
have always somewhat leaned democrat
republicans would win if they could
convince just enough to move on the
other side republicans call themselves
independent on a much higher level
that's why that number's out but what
we're seeing now with pew data is that
there's a specific graph showing
hyperpolarization and you have a larger
portion of democrats becoming republican
independence becoming republican than
the inverse so here's what i see i see
my views
mostly unchanged on principle save the
second amendment
since the past in the past several years
i went from moderate to a we should
respect people's rights but maybe have
some gun control now i'm just outright
you got to change the constitution
before you can do any of the stuff
second amendment second amendment that's
chapter five so
but you you you know to have um
in this country people who are
uninformed on policy or or a specific
industry
try to regulate it and then fail
repeatedly that's exactly why one of the
reasons my positions on this changed
right so when i say something yes i see
what you mean but so so
let me explain the complementary
radicalization please it's not that
my positions have become far right it's
not that my positions have become
increasingly conservative nope i've
always been pro-choice for much of some
in fact i used to be further left when i
was 18. then i became fairly liberal and
i've remained there save uh gun rights i
became a little bit more libertarian
the issue is that the other side is
increasingly becoming authoritarian the
left is is increasingly embracing uh
insane tactics that are destabilizing
the system and then of course i do watch
the right respond in turn
now this is a storm there is no way out
of it but i'll be damned if i'm going to
give up my principles to try and
negotiate with psychopaths so when i say
something but you you just acknowledge
like see this to me seems to be a key
point you're like well the right
response the same way so surely you've
got to get to a point in your country
or just for your own soul where you're
like the psychopaths are everywhere we
need to find a way out from the
psychopaths it's not just the problem is
not just the other side's psychopaths
it's all of the psychopaths well so let
me put it this way
if a guy comes in
if i'm in the middle of a field and i
watch two guys and one guy's like
hanging out with this kid and they're
playing catch
and then some dude in a black mask walks
up and punches in the back of the head
he turns around starts fighting i'm not
gonna be like oh no a fight can we
please compromise i'm gonna be like that
dude punch that guy arrest him arrest
him that guy's defending himself but you
know somewhere there's some guy who's in
a left-leaning podcast who thinks
exactly the same thing except from the
other side and he thinks
but he's i mean
like does it matter it does so i don't
think it matters well listen
joe biden right it is joe biden is not
the source of this no no but i'll give
you an example joe biden
based on all available journalism and
research we've done engaged in a very
serious criminal act with ukraine we
have reporting from the new york times
we have report we have his own
statements we've got uh matt taibi's
reporting we have sworn affidavits out
of ukraine from victor shoken as opposed
to the fully legal activities of donald
trump well give me a specific example
of like i'm just donald trump's illegal
i mean he's about to be charged don't
make the mistake of creating false
binaries and trump has nothing to do
with each other specifically citing joe
biden taking a very specific action with
with respect to ukraine that any
reasonable person can look at the
journalism coming out of this and be
like wow what he did there now look by
all means call out donald trump for any
criminal activity he may have done but
everyone seems to do it he seems to be
in the hot seat 24 7. he was under
investigation for a hoax the russia gate
hoax was just not true but that doesn't
happen to the to the establishment
democrat side or the leftists black
lives matter engages in in in want and
destruction in some of the smallest
towns in this country over 2 billion in
damage
and you and you'll and your perspective
is the right is more dangerous
it's not really my perspective i i would
say that would be the general
perspective of
experts on civil war and the conditions
of the united states i mean those are
the models that i'm working from right
like but i would say like
surely you can see that these these
sides that each side has a case
and that they and that the problem here
is not the problem here is not that
you know what has happened but the fact
that there's no way for anyone
you know democracies only work
when
if you lose you're the other side is
still valid
right like that those are the conditions
that those are the only those are the
conditions of democracy
and so that like what you're saying to
me
is
what i hear is that um that's no longer
possible and that's that's really what
the book is about and that is
like
i'm kind of like i'm imploring you as a
neighbor this is a book written out of
love this is not this is not a book
written out of contempt for the united
states this is a book written out of
profound love for the united states this
is someone who has i've lived in the
united states i've worked there i have a
lot of american friends i have my trump
voting cousin in seattle like you know
i've got like i've i i feel i can't you
know i think canada has a kinship
relationship with america where we're
you know northrop frye the great
literary canadian literary critic said
that a canadian is an american who
rejects the revolution and i think
that's largely true right
quebec was asked
he said no
he said no very close though i mean you
know like the other thing is i come we
almost took montreal 1812 no you had the
worst general yeah the terrible terrible
general in 1812 the real danger was
1860. but um
where was i i now completely lost my
troops
my point though is that
like as someone who is concerned for
your country and as someone who wants
you to have a stable country like you
are going to have to get to a point
where
this is the either come to some kind of
divorce
which seems to me like a
at this when a marriage reaches the
point that the united states is at you
say you'd sit the kids down and say like
it's over
or will lead to violence
well i don't think there's a way to
avoid violence at this point the
question is how do we get out of it you
can't
let me ask you a question stop focusing
on the psychopaths and start focusing on
what's causing psychopathy because if
you try and wipe out the psychopaths
they're just gonna keep appearing
exactly it's not trying to drown a
vampire in blood but let me let me ask
you then um you want to end the conflict
okay what i want is for america to
survive as democracy all right so that
is what i want very specifically how do
you feel about your health care system
in canada i love it okay get rid of that
and go fully private we got a deal
yeah no
no no no no no you have to compromise
with me right will you give up your your
state fund your state you know that's a
fair point
you make it you make it you that's
that's fair i'm sitting i see what you
mean i'm sitting here with people
telling me
that so so uh uh i'm gonna go right into
the stereotype for everybody who's
listening i come from a second
generation mixed race family okay they
fought in my my my grandparents were
forced to flee numerous states because
it was illegal to cohabitate and to have
kids this is something my family
experienced i grow up once again with my
mom who's mixed race marrying a white
guy and having a second generation mixed
race family and i genuinely believed
when i was a kid growing up in chicago
like we had we had come to this position
where we recognized race was less
important martin luther king junior's
dream i was gonna it didn't matter what
i was or my latino friend or my asian
friend we were all just friends in the
neighborhood and then i got to
experience critical race theory and
these people looked me in the eyes and
said i don't know what you are so you're
not allowed to be in any of these groups
but all the white people go there the
black people go there the asians go
there and the mexicans go there that's
what they did at occupy wall street they
were called spokes the spokes council
and they said there were working groups
and there were caucuses and the caucus
caucuses were race-based and
gender-based and so they quite literally
said if you want to vote on how we spend
money all the black people have to go in
the group of black people and decide how
black people want money spent and i said
that's insane and i will fight against
that tooth and nail because my family
experienced this in this past election
in california they tried to repeal their
civil rights amendment from their
constitution
i ask you
you say that we've got to come to this
position where we come together would
you be willing to allow a bunch of white
people in a majority white state to
discriminate against black people in the
name of peace
you know i don't think i'm going to be
faced with that question and certainly
the world is perplexing to me enough
without what-ifs but i'd actually like
to ask you a question because i don't
i don't know the answer to this even
after i spent five years writing this
thing
like
how do you think this is gonna end
i don't i i mean i've heard you say
there's gonna be a civil war
i think we're in a civil war
i mean i think you're well you're
literally in civil strife like like in
in an attack you're in a technical sense
like you are already technically in
civil strife and that was 27 deaths per
year or something no it's 25 but uh like
america is a funny [ __ ] like america's
so big and so diverse and so
geographically huge that those numbers
are probably not as meaningful as they
are in the rest of the world but on the
other hand
i think we're in agreement right is it
an older metric like no it's a standard
metric but it's still not it like
you know america's america's different
right like america is a very different
place like i don't think america is an
exception i don't think the laws of
political gravity don't apply to the
united states but
like
when you're applying these standards
it's just a little it's just a little
more complicated than it would be for
canada right um but on the other hand
like how do you actually so you you
think that do you think political
violence is going to become normalized
that there's just going to be a lot more
assassination do you think there's going
to be do you think there's going to be
street fights do you like
all of those things i can't foresee a
scenario in like you know one of the
problems here is that by 2040 uh 50 of
the country will control 85 of the
senate right so this is like this
becomes like this is classic enocracy so
you know civil wars tend to happen
in
like civil wars don't happen in full
democracies like denmark and they don't
happen in autocracies like russia they
happen when there's a in the gray area
right in this in this area where
it's unclear whether it's democracy or
autocracy so do you think like i can't
foresee a scenario where there will be
an uncontested election ever in the
united states oh you're completely
correct i mean going back to uh
since
uh gore and bush
yeah it's just been and and even then
you still had uh
certain some degree of of strife and
insanity with previous elections but it
was really bad starting then um
there's there's a bunch of different
ways i i i see this
i don't think the right wants to control
the left but the left does want to
control the right
so the right ones to control the country
i disagree
i think so you think the right would be
happy with just the states controlling
their own because i mean one one answer
to this is radical defederalization yes
i mean that's something that's been told
but
we are supposed to be radically
de-federalized yeah i mean we're not
well you already know what i mean but no
but but we're not we're not the fact
that but compared compared to other
people radically compared to other
countries like compared to any country
in europe compared to anywhere in asia
like you are radically de-federalized as
you were traveling the country writing
this geographically did you find
intensity in certain areas
well um
i'm just curious like because
as you were traveling the country
writing this book when you were in state
x where you were like wow i really feel
uh a a a a burgeoning civil war here new
york city i'm from new york city no i uh
texas not to knock texas did you go to
any region that you were like these
people are ready to be separated i found
it i found it everywhere really yeah i
mean it was extraordinary to me the
where i would find it like my friends
who are in media in the hudson valley
they feel very much under threat like
they feel they feel like if you run for
dog catcher as a democrat in hudson
valley someone will send you a picture
of a gun saying we're coming for you
right like never mind
but i mean the thing about america right
now is that everyone feels under siege
right like everyone feels under siege
from one kind or another whether it's
cultural siege whether it's political
siege whether it's siege from the
political machinery right that's the
extraordinary thing right i'm going to
talk to you guys you all feel under
siege yeah
i feel like
i'm going to go down degrees with a
censorship algorithm i mean what you
described like they're trying to take
they're they're hitting me in the back
of the head in an open field well no no
they're trying to tell me to understand
in a segregated world exactly and i will
go and i will go and talk to black lives
matter organizers which i have also done
and they will they will say exactly the
same thing yep they will say they will
say literally exactly the same thing and
they're lying to you
but
that's what they say about you yes
exactly and and and
when russia gate was a hoax when the
covington kids was a hoax when jesse
smallett was a hoax at a certain point
don't you say to yourself maybe they're
lying to me well
then there's the
you know then there's january 6th and
then there's then there's trump calling
up the tanks in washington on the fourth
of july
what is that what is that well in the
fourth of july when we we're in on
walking
so if you want to have someone on to
explain to you the crimes or the right
like if you could definitely find a lot
of people if i'm gonna cite overt
widespread lies and then you cite
january 6 which is unrelated to what i
was talking about i'm going to ask you
oh i think you're asking
well i i mean if i were to count trump's
lies
that's a lo i mean how many hours do we
have here like but like i mean if we're
gonna if we're gonna talk about the the
lies of the right like any trump speech
has 30 of them yeah i don't like but
hold on hold on comparing trump and
buying they're both talking about i'm
not talking about one guy trump is a
symptom of this this i actually say that
in the book you know he's a symptom
rather than a cause right sure so when
you have if you're talking about if
you're asking me like are there any
right wing people who lie that's not
what i'm saying i'm saying
you you would say that black lives
matter would accuse me of lying and my
response is
jesse smallett that thing was an obvious
lie but it was picked up by actors and
celebrities and every mainstream news
organization russia gate was three four
years of outright lying ukraine gate all
of it turned to me to be lies hands up
don't shoot another lie the covington
kids another lie 11 trump
associates have been indicted but
indictments don't mean anything other
than people are at war with each other
john durham is investigating them the
same as they're investigating him what
i'm talking about are you really going
to argue with me are you actually going
to say that the trump administration was
an honest administration you don't
believe i didn't say that
okay so you would admit that they're
lying oh absolutely well there we go but
my point is
trump is
how many viewers does the right command
in terms of institutional media
10 million relative to fox news is the
biggest news organization in the country
by far except they only get about like
three million in total well yeah i mean
we're in media breakdown this is
actually actually a large part of the
structure too like the information
breakdown that's also a big part of the
book but like it's that's actually
that's a you know when i talked about a
complex cascading system that's that
feeds into both sides in in different
ways in asymmetrical ways but um but you
know like one one way of thinking about
this struggle is that it is a memetic
struggle in the jeff joseah you know so
the definition of it here's the point
i'm trying to get to um if you look at
the politically homeless faction the
intellectual dark web faction the
post-liberal faction yes conservatives
and even hardcore maga trump supporters
they all agree for the most part on a
typical world view except for certain
like queue elements which don't make up
that many i i
i don't think i can really agree with i
mean i really tried i mean maybe it is
my own failing but i mean part of my job
was trying to figure out like what are
the intellectual coherences that you
find in this and i found out i mean one
of the things i find really interesting
about the american right in general is
their um
their love of esoteric information right
like an esoteric knowledge where like
something becomes more valuable because
it's less believed
what's an example of that if you have
one well q and on would be like the
ultimate example but where like
is pretty powerful i mean there's two
congress there's 50 people going to run
in 2022 who are queuing on but what does
that mean
well uh 50 50 members of the republican
party support q and on they're going to
run and see here here's the issue i
think you might have we've had marjorie
taylor green on the show yeah and she's
she's set rejected all of that stuff
so when you don't actually do space
lasers and so on that's not true
actually that's fake that's a lie
right so if you if you base your
perception off a faction that it's lying
to you non-stop of course you're going
to believe well that both sides must be
bad margaritas do not understand that
i've had this con this exact
conversation with people on the left and
i've i've actually stated exactly this
in 100 plus shows of this that that the
reason civil war in my opinion is
inevitable is because you have two sides
both saying i'm right i'll give you i'll
give you an example a riddle
uh you may have heard this one this will
be fun for all the kids at home don't
tell me i want to guess
you come across you're walking down a
road and you come to a fork in the road
and you see
there's there's two paths and
and you know that once one road will
lead you to a minute death and one road
will lead you to safety there are two
men standing on each side oh yes the old
one and how do you know one always tells
the truth one always tells a lie i know
how do you want how do you know i heard
it differently which road is the is the
right path is it oh god i know it you
asked
well i've heard it as as i've heard it
as heaven and hell yeah where one the
angel always tells the truth and the
devil always tells a lie and you ask
the devil
no no you ask the angel is the other one
at death you don't know
which one is which
yeah i can't remember it i've heard it
you ask either one of them what the
other would say right and then take the
opposition take the opposite path yeah
so so the issue here is
there there is obviously
a more complex system of variables here
well that's my point but
right like that's that's that's actually
a really good way of putting it so if if
that's the condition where one's the
angel and one's the devil and you don't
know
which one is right
like surely we have to come up with
something more clever than the other
side's wrong
i suppose the issue is
the reason i use the biden example is
because if you were to ask
the average journalist in this country
did joe biden engage in a quid pro quo
in ukraine they will tell you no but the
actual answer is yes he did i i think
journalists actually are pretty
complicated i mean i know a lot of them
you know as i said i'm a freelance
writer so one of the advantages i have
is that i go into a lot of shops i'm
like a stray cat like i go into the wall
street journal in the new york times in
new york or the atlantic and so on like
and i i would say that the
the general opinion that the american
media are all the same
that's not that's not necessarily true
what is true is that people who went to
ivy league schools
tend to be tend to have a a very similar
outlook on life these these
organizations
most of them are new york or they tend
to be in big cities where they're
surrounded by like-minded people i would
say they're they're only as far as i
know they're only in new york washington
and l.a but let me ask you to uh because
i think the best example is the biden
thing were you aware that joe biden
engaged in a criminal quid pro quo i'm
not sure i would define it that way but
also i'm not sure i have that whole
story so this is like and you know when
i don't like there's a lot of things
don't you you know i was with the
president well there was a bunch i was
at a i was at a cottage with these
friends i have who are in their 80s and
one guy told me to really they were all
giving me life advice and this old dude
said you know one of the most important
things in life is to know you don't have
to have an opinion on everything
you don't have to think
i know the answer to x when you don't
and so i actually go through life
not knowing the answer to almost
everything and so when i write books
what i try and do is figure out exactly
what i do know
and like and like and and also be clear
about where i got my knowledge let me
see like i don't like what happened with
biden in the ukraine i don't know
shouldn't you though i mean if you're
writing about a civil war and there have
been accusations made up against donald
trump in terms of a quid pro quo i don't
remember donald trump does not figure in
this book
like neither does biden like to me
honestly horse race politics irrelevant
yeah like horseradish like what marjory
taylor green said what ted cruz said
today irrelevant like the structural
problems that the united states faces
are so profound
that
all of the politics to me that consumes
everything in it is all irrelevant like
it it really really does not matter the
the reason i bring it up is just um to
try and set like a baseline so yeah i i
started uh covering occupy wall street i
had worked i had been an activist in my
younger years i work for nonprofits i go
to occupy wall street i start
documenting things and i say i just want
to show people what's happening i end up
getting a job advice and being the
founding member of vice news right doing
on the ground reporting in ukraine and
brazil and venezuela and then from there
i went and joined abc univision's joint
venture once again trying to do news but
that's where they got hyper-polarized
they within six months of me being there
they said we're far left that's our
that's our pitch right we are targeting
progressive young people oh as a
freelancer you think i don't see that
but so institutions all the time that
i'm part of suddenly become
hyper-polarized but it's always to the
left
well institutionally yes no that you're
fair that's fair so here's
they almost always go hyper-polarized
left so so here's then they immediately
die like that's the other thing vice's
evaluation right right like they like
they go what that's one of my points
about the left is like once you once an
institution becomes woke it almost
immediately starts that's my favorite
about the federal reserve i'm gonna make
this point slow like i gotta i'm sorry
yeah i'm sorry i don't mean to interrupt
you no i know i'm talking a lot this one
but i do want to make this point is that
as a baseline
i've been reading the news and doing the
research and the fact checking on all of
these stories and it's come to a point
where
the right tends to be correct on these
things and the left goes off into wally
world every time ukraine gate being a
really great example of the corporate
press
the establishment democrats and the left
all lying about what joe biden did with
respect to ukraine when more and more
reporting keeps coming out proving he
actually did this even based on the
mainstream his own previous reporting
say from politico politico publishes a
story as is the new york times that
ukrainians meddled in the 2016 election
in an effort to help democrats not that
the ukrainian government did but that
elements of you know higher ranking
officials in ukraine did
a court even ruled this in ukraine joe
biden engages in a quid pro quo where he
brags about it on camera
but if you come out and say that you're
called right wing they say it's fake
news you're lying and it's not true i
live in a world based on do you have
sources for that just the other night we
got reporting that the person who tried
to assassinate the democrat was a blm
activist and i said no no no no no
we are not that is a rumor is not
confirmed until we can get official
confirmation on this story even though
there had been i just hadn't seen it
because if i don't have the official
reporting from a trusted source it
didn't happen but every single time i go
to the news a good majority of what's
considered mainstream corporate press is
right wrong and they defend it for
example the crack pipe story jen sackey
goes on tv and says we were never going
to give out crack pipes that's a lie
easily proved by looking at the
organizations they were contracting who
give crack pipes i pulled up two
different sources international and
national let's say safe smoking kits
include meth and crack pipes yet when
when the right comes out and says this
snope says false all of the corporate
establishment press are saying it's not
true there were never any crack pipes
then gentecki goes on tv and says why
did they know crack pipes why would why
was there an objection to them giving
out crack pipes the right felt it could
possess
exacerbate crack pipe smoke
see in canada i remember in the 90s
there was bad there was a i remember
going to parties and there was a
government program to give out um straws
for snorting cocaine
because it was because it was being uh
aids was right communicated nasally and
so i remember i was like yeah that's
that's just the government i like they
give out
some places for stories
listen so this is what happens but
listen do you do you honestly are you
honestly telling me that you feel like
when you see something on fox news you
feel like it's probably correct and then
it's not and then it's and then it's and
that you've never seen a story on fox
news that was not was a lot no i call
out fox news it's just i call them out
lessons well then what are i mean
and fox's one station compared to the
problem here the problem here is the
informational networks it's not the
sides that's what i'm trying to tell you
but what ends up happening is after a
decade of this
it has become so divergent
that you cannot convince an 18 year old
who's voting for these policies that the
majority of their life was based on lies
so i i'll give you another example of
what's caused all this and i don't know
if you looked into this but um in the
late have you looked at the lexus nexus
data on cr on critical race theory and
woke terminology
no i don't i have not checked that at
the end of 2000 of the 2000s lexus nexus
tracks massive spikes in the new york
times saying things like white privilege
racism class privileges you don't need
lexisnexis to tell you that right well
so several things happened one
millennials who were in colleges who are
being who are learning these things
started to age into the workforce but
the biggest thing that happened was
facebook created the algorithms that
prop up content based on how many
keywords are in them
so someone who's eight years old it goes
on facebook and they start getting
inundated with videos of police
brutality for 10 years why because it
clicks really well anger and justice
themes do really really well on facebook
but so does the opposite dude i mean
definitely i mean like and your
injustice can go either way well
like the
i mean
i i i feel like i'm repeating myself but
like
surely we can all see that like i i've
i've definitely not been a friend to
wokeness you can read more you can read
my writing on it like i've been punished
enough
but like like just to be clear like
what would
my point here is really this that the
crisis that your country is facing is so
severe
that
that these these debates are
increasingly meaningless because they
take place in a context of
you know essentially semantic collapse
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you